- [Woman] What's scary
about being an entrepreneur?
- You know the truth is I don't
even know how to fully answer
that because I don't, that's
like asking me what's the best
thing about being a human being
or what's the greatest part of
breathing oxygen, right?
Like, you know, I,
I mean the best part
for me is that I'm
doing what I think I naturally
was born to do. It was kind of
like what was the worst part of
my life between six and 18 years
old and that was I was forced to
do school in a world where that
was like ripping my eye
directly out of my head.
Right?
- [Woman] Right.
- To me, the best part is
it's my natural being it's who
I am and I love entrepreneurship
and meritocracy and capitalism
and market behavior so much
I even like them more
than my own well-being.
I secretly think that if
I deserve to go out of business
that that would excite me
because I think I deserve it.
Right?
I love the game so
much that I'm often...
For example, right now we're in
a very political climate and I'm
yelling at all my old white dude
rich friends in their 60s and
70s who think they're capitalist
still because they want a
Republican president to protect
their money and I'm like,
"You're god damn loser because
you think that just because you
"made the money you're
entitled to save it."
Nobody, nobody is keeping
IBM or Google or
AT&amp;T or BMW alive.
That's the market and nobody
should keep an individual alive.
This is capitalism.
This is business and you should
grind forever and if you take
the foot off the
peddle in your 50s,
60s, 70s and 80s you
should lose upside.
You should lose and so I just
love the game of business and
entrepreneurship and
to me that excites me and
that's the best part.